danny trejo is giving us all the friday  feels as he snuggles with his adorable  rescue dogs and trust us listening to  danny baby talk as dogs is well worth  your time we'll see ya  oh look at that look at what good  puppies you know what i'm just a dog  person cats  cats remind me of movie stars they think  they're so entitled i love dogs i don't  like people that don't like dogs  good boy it was a half [ __ ] hi baby with  your little  it's a little fat tummy  [Music]  i've had dogs all my life my first  recollection of dogs  is  we had three my uncle's dog was named  butch we had butch blackie and bazu from  the gate i was that kid that would say  hey he followed me home and i have him  on a rope you know  i think the good lord wants us to start  living up to all our responsibilities  these are like the love of my life  besides my kids and uh my daughter's a  favorite okay so